hey everyone bandit here if i were to
say the words
yahoo or
let's go to you would that remind you of
anybody in particular
no
well no worries it's just that there's
this video game character named mario or
mario mario more specifically who's
known for saying those exact words
he's also the most popular video game
character of all time if mario is known
for doing one thing it's jumping heck
his original name before he was known as
mario was jumpman back when he was busy
battling giant apes instead of giant
fire-breathing turtles and if mario's
jumping is known for one other thing
it's jumping into and hitting blocks i
mean brick blocks question mark blocks
invisible blocks indestructible blocks
you name it it's probably a block
somewhere in the mario universe but what
if i told you that for the past 35 years
of players getting to gleefully jump
into blocks and break them or collect
coins and whatnot there has been a dark
sinister meaning behind it this entire
time i mean of course the mario universe
is a fictional one that takes place with
fictional rules that enables things like
blocks to be floating around in the sky
but even within this fictional universe
there are certain things that have
explanations that have long since been
hidden from the public eye due to their
dark nature and i'm not even
exaggerating just watch the video you'll
see what i mean some of you that have
been in the mario theory realm for a
while may remember a theory going around
several years ago on places like reddit
that detailed a dark secret behind the
coins in mario games and to be honest
with you since this theory is going to
cover a game franchise that's well over
three decades old there's probably a
pretty good possibility that this is
going to be information you may have
heard of before but this was all new to
me and i'm at the ripe old age of 20
something so i'm hoping it's new to most
of you too this theory encompasses the
old reddit one but branches out even
further to set the stage for our
speculation let's talk about a long
forgotten piece of mario lore regarding
everyone's favorite fire breathing koopa
bowser's always going
nope not that bowser the other bowser
bowser's always going around messing
stuff up that mario and company have to
fix right be it stealing princesses or
otherwise destroying the land but have
you ever thought about what exactly it
is that makes bowser so special and
gives him some pretty supernatural
powers well as far as his size and shape
of his face is concerned that's
something that probably should be
covered in another theory but let's
focus on his supernatural powers for now
in addition to fire breath the big
baddie's been shown being able to fly
fabricate powerful lightning and even
teleport not to mention his immense
amounts of strength and stamina clearly
he has access to some sort of magical
powers the question is what are they
well let me read to you a little snippet
from the game manual of the original
super mario brothers it reads one day
the kingdom of the peaceful mushroom
people was invaded by the koopa a tribe
of turtles famous for their black magic
black magic like straight up witchcraft
and obviously the koopa tribe has a
leader also known as the koopa king also
known as bowser so there you have it
bowser has these abilities because he
practices black magic but it gets even
weirder remember all those blocks in the
games i mean how could you forget check
this out the quiet peace-loving mushroom
people were turned into mere stones
bricks and even field horse hair plants
and the mushroom kingdom fell into ruin
well that's pretty straight forward it
even says on page 8 that you can come
across quote mushrooms that have been
turned into bricks directly through dark
magic bowser was able to create all the
blocks you see in super mario games
specifically the stones mario runs on in
super mario brothers which we know are
stone because they're brown and cracked
and contrast heavily with the green
assumedly grassy hills in the background
the bricks that mario can jump into or
on top of and field horse hair plants
which uh are these things that that
thing right there i guess i don't know
what that is why bowser would do this to
the people of the mushroom kingdom i'm
not sure maybe it was a creative attempt
at thinning their numbers or something i
guess although a lot of them end up
helping mario in the long run with
power-ups and stuff like that so i'm not
sure that one was thought out too well
mr koopa and he keeps doing it every
time he threatens the piece of the
mushroom kingdom but speaking of
power-ups things are about to get even
weirder believe it or not see as it's
been theorized before on the web like i
mentioned earlier since we know now that
there's a pretty dark backstory behind
all the magical floating bricks in mario
games the next natural question we have
to ask is what is up with what comes out
of the bricks in super mario bros games
the coins that our plump plumber
collects aren't used for you know buying
stuff or anything like that i mean it's
not like anyone uses coins for currency
anyway but what they are used for
instead now has much darker implications
see in super mario brothers games which
are the side scrolling platforming games
based off of the original mario coins
are collected for one thing and one
thing only one ups and score but nobody
cares about that the coins give mario an
extra life or one up when he collects
100 of them oh what a nice innocent game
mechanic said the viewer but it's not
actually retorted bandit as the
aforementioned old reddit theory
insinuated because coins strangely give
mario life and because they refill his
life meter in the super mario games like
mario 64 sunshine and galaxy what if
these coins which come from bricks also
known as transformed mushroom people are
actually the souls or spirits of said
mushroom people i mean why else would
the coins disappear on impact with mario
and then either heal him when he's
damaged or add to his life count in
total the old reddit theory proves this
coin soul connection further by talking
about the fireflower which is probably
mario's most famous powerup besides a
superstar see when you kill an enemy
normally by jumping on top of their head
they just die and give you a certain
amount of points for your score at the
end of the level but if you burn one of
them to death with a fire flower's flame
they yield a coin this could be because
you are completely destroying the
enemy's body with fire as opposed to
simply you know smooshing them or
hitting them with a shell the thing is
that's not the only thing that these
bricks can produce they can also
sometimes yield the superstar
which is a famous power-up that gives
mario invincibility for a short amount
of time something that again affects
mario's life force directly this may
happen when multiple souls of mushroom
people are bound to the same brick and
if these brick drops don't prove the
connection yet they also drop some
straight up mushrooms as powerups hint
hint like the green one up mushroom
which directly adds to mario's life
count instead of having to collect 100
coins or the red magic mushroom which
turns little mario into super mario guys
honestly most of this video isn't even a
theory it's just confirmed material the
only part that's speculative is whether
or not the coins and mushroom power-ups
and superstars are the souls of the
mushroom people that were trapped inside
the blocks which in my opinion is pretty
darn believable at this point
[Music]
but as dark as this cursed mushroom
people reality is it's got a bright side
to it at least see i think the mushroom
people are willingly giving these soul
gifts to mario not to sound too
depressing but it's not like they were
going anywhere and this is pretty dark
but i would assume that if i were turned
into an immobile brick for the rest of
my existence i would probably be okay
with giving up my soul so that the hero
of our story could save the world you
know probably i mean i guess it depends
on what kind of setup i had in my flying
mini brick room ultimately their souls
were used by mario to defeat bowser and
release princess peach back into the
mushroom kingdom who according to the
manual is the only one who can return
the mushroom people back to normal which
is great but unless she can create souls
as well as remove the transformation
black magic it looks like some of the
brave mushrooms that gave their souls to
mario won't be coming back any time soon
but that's just my theory what did you
guys think are coins and power-ups the
souls of the trapped mushroom people
from inside the bricks or are they
something else like the left behind good
magic of princess peach let me know in
the comments below also thank you so
much for watching if you would please
consider leaving a like on the video if
you liked the video to get it spread
around on youtube and help grow the
channel a bit and subscribe if you
haven't already for much more awesome
nintendo deep dives to come and let me
know in the comments below if you'd like
to see more super mario theories as that
is another franchise that i love dearly
as do i'm sure a lot of you as always
huge thanks to my bandit crew who make
my day every single day if you're
interested in helping these videos get
made and keeping old bandit doing bandit
things feel free to click that join
button located below or follow the links
in the description for my patreon or
merch pages that's all i've got for this
one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mass
intent abandoned looking forward to
seeing you in the next one and signing
out
[Music]
you